s'est passé un truc extraordinaire c'est
que le musée créé par appelait alors le
musée grévin voilà connaissez le musée
grévin
c'est un honneur pour moi parce que
c'est que des stars au musée grévin
voilà donc ils reproduisent à
l'identique
donc là votre statut et votre physique
et votre personnalité et séries m'ont
appelé et il m'a demandé de rentrer au
musée grévin donc j'ai dit oui j'ai fait
des essayages fait des trucs parce que
c'est un maire n'est pas possible tu
fais pleins d'essayage et 90 sérieux
quoi ça rigole pas là des gens qui font
un travail de fou voilà c'est je les ai
tous adoré ou ses
sept ans à 94 7 ans 94
94 donc ils ont 18 ans à faire là c'est
moi c'est nous enlever les images de ce
qu'on va devo les voies dévoilé merci
voilà donc et c'est vrai que j'ai dix
ont démarré la statue 187
ce soir ils sont avec nous pour nous
dévoiler la statue ya véronique
responsable des relations extérieures du
musée grévin et yves delot mots dits
déchets c'est le directeur général du
musée ils sont avec nous ce soir
applaudissements
l'un m'a dit pendant sa malheureuse nous
remercient d'être lâché comment ça va
merci alors je tiens à dire un peu tous
les deux on s'est souvent vu avec
dorothée passer aux verrous et je
l'adorent dayraut voilà du musée grévin
yves aussi à chaque fois ils m'ont
accueilli ça a été un bonheur et je suis
très heureux alors comment comment ça se
passe ce que tu peux expliquer aux
téléspectateurs
je peux le faire je le fais basit nous
en fait c'est plus de six mois de
travail pour réaliser un personnage
assez petit donc
on a pris le temps puis un confinement
et puis des événements etc on a voulu
peaufiner et d'ailleurs on a une bible
je ne la quitte pas parce que en fait
cyril hanouna c'est aussi tous ses
chroniqueurs donc on a pris la
substantifique moelle de chacun de vous
pour en faire un personnage mann et donc
pour faire un personnage aussi - travail
des séances de pose que cyril accent
c'est avec beaucoup de bonheur et on
s'est bien amusés des coûts de travail
de toute l'équipe beaucoup de travail de
toute l'équipe le sculpteur qui a révisé
le personnage s'appelle claus velte et
[Rires]
j'ai ferrand accéléré et dont il ya tout
le modelage en place du lean et ensuite
il ya tout le moulage
ensuite le nak ou gonesse qui ça fait un
peu gras l'huile c'est un personnage
pourquoi ça coûte très cher à santini le
décor 60000 euros trouvés l'ayant battu
dans son cher que tous les chroniques
récompensée d'un lion
et le sont toujours offertes par des
personnalités chez moi qui lui permet
d'être en cercle sachez qu'un joker de
michael jackson qui nous avait offert
dimanche à remercier qui habite
d'ailleurs
merci à eux merci merci yves merci en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est un honneur
pour moi c'est leur job mais on y est il
va re elle va rentrer quand au musée
alors celle là alors dès demain je sais
on est invité alors vous êtes invités en
permanence pour voir si vous payez
je serais pas ici vous avez votre pass
élite exactement alors que ce procès que
j'aimerais que le président de ses 8
[Applaudissements]
oui alors il était au courant n'était
pas au courant thiery il est tout ému je
rentre au musée mais cela était tout ému
les chutes soudaines saisir c'est
vraiment un chalet j'allais je sais pas
quand même soit dans ma vie au musée
grévin et mal an ti
[Musique]
c mon amour mon amour tu vois là
vraiment je t'aime et à côté non loin
d'où vous serez alors je serais moi et
bien pratiquement à l'entrée d'accord du
parcours est tout près il y aura omar sy
très bien que tu sais tu es venu pour ça
et on savait rien oui tout à fait
actuelle de 30 seulement non et on a
payé angelina scioli monica l'année qui
vient
[Applaudissements]
je connais ça ça va vouloir de pécho
tabac arrange pas c'est pas bon c'est
pas bon pour le music
patricia d'or aussi alors on va voir
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
monde au xix ghallab rapide par exemple
à brad pitt ont regardé brad pitt
regarder on va voir brad pitt y en avoir
sa statue voilà brad pitt passé lui on
connaît voilà très bien
très beau yahya baya os-marsillon mal à
paris où mon frère omar sy voilà jeté à
lui j'avais découvert sa statue égouts
away est réussi il ya matt pokora on
ferait un autre héros aussi qu'ils
informent matt pokora alors maintenant
je veux qu il faut après vous vous
moduler parce qu'il a joué court
maintenant match et a vécu cet été bah
il faut s'aimer et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il va falloir essayer pas toutes ces
petites bottes way va falloir qu'on va
permanente et permanent
alors il ya carla bruni - carla bruni
magnifique car la vraie les guitares
kenza hébert son père sony elias de la
tonne hier la tan également oui bah
ouais
alors on va découvrir eux donc je me dis
niveau coiffure et les spas
niveau coiffer un
nouveau concurrent n'est pas non mais on
va y est on va y aller demain on va
prendre le nom savoir combien de chevaux
petit baby
- les cheveux que le nez très concret on
va investir dans la cour avec moi je la
découvre
[Applaudissements]
203 galeries
oui
m
à
un
jeune homme à côté
c'est beau
ils sont traités
les yeux c'est les fonctionnaires mais
les yeux ses excès des noms mais ça
paraît que vous avez quoi vous sert
alors il ya juste la coiffure c'est vrai
que la cour puis voilà jean-michel week
end à michel
c'était votre coiffure de l'année
dernière les bouclettes c'est mieux
ces mariages est le père
françois rey
et je te remercie aussi
mon ami stéphane bern ces parties du
tout à fait c'est l'académie grévin
exactement que j'aime mon stéphane
j'embrasse mon bon stéphane bern alors
que j'aime et voilà et ben est
franchement donc la saluer toutes les
équipes c'est vrai
les regarde et s'est même offert les
maquettes maintenant le basket basket où
ça y'a plus cher en fringant statut je
suis sûr
qu'on aime chili merci à vous de mercy
verrou
en plus je viens de marché voulait mais
qui dit merci
[Applaudissements]